je voudrais m'adresser au peuple
au peuple français qui malgré la fatigue
et la lassitude de cinq années de
confrontation permanente de dégradation
de son niveau de vie de privation y
compris de des libertés individuelles et
des libertés collectives aspire je crois
à la tranquillité aspirent au retour du
bon sens dans la gestion des affaires de
l'état
le bon sens par exemple d'aider les plus
vulnérables de nos compatriotes ceux qui
sont en situation d'handicap les 25 % de
familles monoparentales plutôt que ceux
qui avaient la chance de pays sf le bon
sens de mettre des régulations à une
mondialisation dont le peuple voit bien
que la brutalité et l'aveuglément
déstabilisent l'économie française le
bon sens d' empêcher de nuire les
prédateurs d'en haut 1 ceux qui pillent
nos fleurons nationaux et qui font de
l'optimisation fiscale et puis les
prédateurs d'en bas c'est à dire les
délinquants et les criminels 1 qui
harcèlent les braves gens et qu'il faut
bien dire pourrissent leur existence le
bon sens de protéger de notre système de
de notre système social de manière
globale les retraites la santé notre
système d'indemnisation et du chômage
qui permet en fait de faire face aux
aléas de la vie et sans craindre en
permanence pour le lendemain le bon sens
de privilégier l'enracinement à la
spéculation
le localisme globalisme la transmission
à la spoliation la valeur travail à libé
risation de nos emplois d'accorder une
priorité aux français dans leur propre
pays pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'en réalité ils n'en ont qu'un
le bon sens en train de défendre ce qui
fait l'âme de la france comme le font
d'ailleurs tous les pays du monde
monsieur macron notre identité nos
traditions nationales et locales nos
valeurs notre langue nos paysages et de
le faire sans complexe ce projet est
viable il est même je le crois vital
c'est celui en tout cas que je porte
pour les français pour tous les français
et bien voilà
[Musique]